[Music]
it makes perfect sense for us to be
eating invasive species because invasive
species are an endless resource for food
my name is Bonnie I'm the chef that Mia
is sushi in New Haven 33 years ago my
mother started me as reimagining sushi
is something that is restorative of the
environment this is part of the regimen
that happens every day in the morning
foraging one of the things that we're
really focused on is invasive species
what if we start focusing on ingredients
that nobody else wants to eat that are
abundant and even destructive in the
environment and by pulling them out of
the environment will help rebalance that
habitat this is wild lettuce and we're
gonna serve them with bug holes in them
it's like Swiss cheese that means that
they're they're healthy to eat and that
their pesticide herbicide free here's a
big one really can't has it they have to
be fully committed to pitching see if I
am it got shot they're a lot stronger
than you think he's really pushing off
my hand yeah we're set to go it's rock n
roll
[Music]
great these snails from Europe they're
called European snails came over stuck
on ships I feel like you're like a big
kid just crawling around looking under
rocks what I'm collecting it's always
incredibly exciting it's very thrilling
for me well alright but when I'm trying
to figure out new ways of working with
an ingredient that I've never worked
with before or an ingredient that
actually grosses me out I like the fact
that I'm forcing myself to confront my
own prejudices today we went foraging
for dandelion amaranth wild lettuce
mugwort butterbur grasshopper invasive
European snails a whole bunch of Asian
shore crabs and wacom is seaweed in
Brussels area seaweed are you gonna be
mad if we show the whole world that you
can make gourmet sushi just using stuff
in your backyard that's what we want the
whole world to do or consider doing or
think about doing and not only that this
isn't an original idea people have been
doing this for tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of years way
before before me is and it's delicious
and it's absolutely delicious and
nutritious and great for the environment
[Music]
yeah buddy home on old motor scooter oh
yeah hormones I already messed it up
they don't know viva la la cara Thomas
[Music]
retraction on of Iowa sasaki uterus
economy teeny heightened or ideological
others so recover this car I aku don't
you gonna dock you say morning tinker
stay you know konichiwa Remus
Homer not usually I hate a Jew named
laughs still at all but I should avoid
us
and miss anymore anymore don't worry
though soon woman missing emoji re
mascara story should another through
worship tomato get Orthodox until you
say taco taco taco tuna rice too excited
to us each do a few committee which I do
not watch that among us Mike I know is
it's made sure - g'day a very
wishy-washy colonial night actually
she needed a yes Suraj Rana who divine
you are so mortgaged a good super Ashima
notes Kaiba so doc a cure that's a chic
about Hawaii
you know psychopathology idea
opening stone oh you know choice got
that Cody's been one of the schedule
said ten yawns and ominous who didn't
know me never got home we must
[Music]
this is a California roll
and it was probably invented in Japan
wrong-o California nope
it was invented in Canada this is chef
Tojo right this is chef Roger he helped
make sushi one of the most popular foods
in the US and Canada but to understand
this we have to take a look back it was
1971 and sushi
wasn't popular when it came to Japanese
food people only liked a couple things
just people ET temple us and also
teriyaki turns out North Americans they
did not like seaweed no no no way look
terrible they said some people yeah do
you know so Tojo did something crazy he
wrapped the rice on the outside of the
sea to hide it in Japan people they
passing me well this is a long idea
wrong idea but people like it and chef
Tojo he did not stop there okay
everybody eat cucumber avocado and
cooked crab just I change this
preparation just low so he rolled his
preferred ingredients into one beautiful
amazing cuisine changing roll I didn't
call to California Lord we called inside
I don't know where it is it got the name
California roll because it was so
popular with people who came to his
restaurant from LA and the roll made
people think differently about sushi it
was some sort of gateway roll people
starting with California law oh this is
very good then smoked salmon and tuna
step by step they loved it chef Tojo's
beginner roll was such a success Japan's
Ministry of Agriculture Forestry and
Fisheries appointed him as the nation's
goodwill ambassador for Japanese cuisine
and now sushi is everywhere stickers on
your notebook USB drives play-doh molds
wooden toys sets everywhere maybe not
all thanks to chef Tojo but definitely
partly
[Music]
salmon sushi isn't Japanese it's
Norwegian huh okay here's the story
until about 1995 raw salmon was not
consumed in Japan and this was for one
big reason Pacific salmon has parasites
oh so no salmon sushi sashimi no spicy
salmon nothing what but obviously that
all changed thanks in part to this guy
Norway had a problem they had a lot of
salmon and too small a market looking
east they set their sights on Japan a
country that loves raw fish so much it's
willing to pay five times the price yes
for sushi grade so noir we formed a
committee and hired bjorn from 1986 to
1991 I worked for okay their job was to
convince Japanese consumers that
Atlantic salmon was safe to consume raw
and this was hard just take for example
pork if some guy from Norway came here
and said here er pork meat raw it's safe
it's really yummy we'd be like man
you're crazy it was basically a matter
of perception so we had to change the
whole country Buuren and his team got to
work they made the first ever salmon
rolls and serve them to businessmen in
Japan which they didn't like for a long
time it took actually 10 years ok I get
the proper breakthrough in the market so
there it is salmon sushi didn't exist
before 1995 Buuren on behalf of the
world we thank you
[Music]
when you think of Japanese cuisine a few
foods come to mind sushi did you know
that salmon sushi is actually norwegian
yeah we did a story on that one maybe
you think of mochi we did that one too
and tempura but guess what tempura is
actually a Portuguese dish oh boy here
we go
the Japanese tempura you know is done
two ways either with seafood or with
vegetables right and the batter is light
made with cold water wheat flour and egg
pretty standard this tempura can be
found dating back to the end of the 16th
century in Japan but as we know Japan is
much older than that so why did it
suddenly show up
the answer is Portugal around 15 43 a
Chinese ship with three Portuguese
sailors got off course and landed in
Japan on Tanegashima Island fast forward
a bit and the Portuguese because of this
happy accident are now trading goods and
arms with the Japanese then in 1639 the
Portuguese were kicked out of country a
few things however remained including a
dish of battered and fried beans called
machines they or thought equal version
subject here pushing your sword that's
Manuela brandão chef at Papa service one
of the best spots in Lisbon to get a
cheese dosa question is no article
sustained face over the Gazebo possible
Yahoo's inform you every 300s are garden
where those Agra Davao the second of the
society who because racine are OSHA for
me is vision now of course over the past
400 years Japan has put its own spin on
the dish but you know it's a fun fact
next time somebody in your group orders
tempura
you